مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه نرحب
باللواء فايز الدويري ونبدا من الخارطه
التفاعليه معك سلام والحديث اليوم من ول
ستريت جورنال عن ان القتال يعود حتى الى
تلك المناطق التي يفترض انه قد انتهى فيها
كما يقول الاسرائيليون صحيح وتقول ايضا
بانه لا يبدو هناك اي افق لانتهاء الحرب
رغم وجود ال الجهود الدبلوماسيه لوصول الى
اتفاق بين حركه المقاومه وبين قوات
الاحتلال ولكن الاهم ما قاله عثمان بالطبع
هو ان الاشتباكات عادت لتندلع في اكثر من
نقطه كانت قد توقفت فيها خلال الايام
الماضيه وان كانت هذه العوده بشكل محدود
وعند نقاط محدده دون غيرها واحده من هذه
النقاط هي غرب مدينه غزه شهدت هذه المنطقه
اشتباكا محدودا بين القوات الاحتلال وبين
المقاومه وكتائب القسام قالت انها استهدفت
ايضا في هذه النقاط عده مجموعات تابعه ل
قوات الاحتلال بقذائف اما محموله على
الكتف موجهه الى الاليات وايضا جنود مشات
كانوا برفقه هذه الاليات بموازاه ما يجري
في قطاع في غرب مدينه غزه ايضا شهدت بيت
لهيا قصفا بالطائرات اغارت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه على عده مناطق في بيت هي اقصى
شمال القطاع المنطقه الوسطى بدورها ليست
هادئه ونحن ما زلنا نتحدث عن نفس القوس
الذي كنا نتحدث عنه في الايام الماضيه
البريج والمغازي والمصدر ولكن تحديدا عند
مخيم المغازي يبدو انه يستمر بكونه مكانا
سهلا ل كتائب المقاومه لاستهداف القوات
الاسرائيليه اليوم قوه اسرائيليه موجوده
عند تخوم المغازي هاجمتها كتائب القسام
وسرايا القدس واوقعت فيها خسائر وايضا
خسائر في الاليات بعد عمليتين نوعيتين
متتاليتين شهده ما مخيم المغازي امس كان
هناك اس استدراج لمجموعه راجله من قوات
الاحتلال من جنود قوات الاحتلال الى احد
الانفاق في مخيم المغازي والقسام قالت
انها فجرت النفق فيهم ثم قامت
باستهداف قوه مسانده للق قوه المشات التي
دخلت الى النفق عند تخوم المغازي واوقعت
فيهم قتلى وجرحى قدرتهم بنحو ثمانيه جنود
حتى الان لم تعلن قوات الاحتلال عن هذه
الخسائر وهذا امر معهود تتاخر اسرائيل
عاده بالاعلان عن خسائرها خان يونس
المدينه وخان يونس المحافظه ايضا هي مركز
قتال شديد بل الاعنف تستمر فيها العمليات
منذ بدايه شهر سبتمبر الماضي تقريبا قاربت
على اكمال شهرين المعارك في خان يونس وحتى
الان لا تزال تسير بشده وعنف سنذهب الى
صوره اكثر قربا هذه بعض تفاصيل خان يونس
على مستوى الشوارع والمناطق اليوم شاهدنا
فيديو لكتائب القسام يظهر هذا الفيديو
بوضوح توغل اليه اسرائيليه اي داخل احد
الازقه في المخيم واستهداف مباشر من كتائب
القسام من نقطه مرتفعه استهدفت برج هذه
الدبابه على الاقل اليه واحده وا ربما
هناك اليتين اثنتين واندلعت الغبار
واحترقت الاليه بحسب ما يظهر في الفيديو
هذا كله عثمان بحاجه الى قراءه معك
واللواء الدويري نعم سلام شكرا وهذه
القراءه ناخذها منك سياده اللواء ونبدا
بتعليقك على على ما ذكرته سلام يعني اولا
كما ذكرت هناك ثلاث مناطق عمليات العمليات
مختلفه
ومتباينه المنطقه الشماليه لا نقول هنا
يعني هناك اشتباكات محدوده تدخلات
محدوده لانه هي
تتتبع امور محدده اي ظهور للمقاتلين اي
معلومات عن الرهائن اي معلومات عن اكتشاف
انفاق وبالتالي كلما ظهر اي من هذه الامور
وتوفرت معلومات ت قوم بالتدخل حتى منذ
لحظه الاعلان وزير الدفاع عن الانسحاب لم
تكن هناك معارك بمعنى معارك الا في تقريبا
ثلاثه ايام كانت في التفاح والدرج وفي
جباليا مخيم جباليا ومن ثم تراجعت حده
القتال وانسحبت ان كفه قوات جيش الاحتلال
في المنطقه الوسطى كما تحدثت تم الفصل بين
ال المخيمات الاربعه وال لا يوجد معارك
حاسمه بمعنى معارك حاسمه في شمال الصيرات
منذ اكثر من اسبوعين توقفت قوات ال عمليات
الهجوم في البريج كذلك ظهر المغازي في
الايام الاخيره كان الثقب الاسود وبالتالي
الزوايدي تم اخذ جزء منه الى منطقه
المستم الحديقه العامه وتقريبا الى اوضاع
هي عباره عن اشتباكات ي الان يوجد
لكل منطقه يوجد لواء يوجد اربعه الويه في
ه المنطقه ويوجد الويه في وادي غزه هي
التي تديم الاشتباك مع منطقه الشيخ عجلين
وتل الهواء اللي اشارت له اي زميله الان
اذا ذهبنا الى الجنوب لا هناك المعارك
المعارك كسر العظم يعني اي يعني يحق ان
نقول انها معارك كسر العظم ويجب ان
تقسم شارع صلاح الدين يقسم منطقه العمليات
الان شرق منطقه العمليات هي رغم انه الجهد
الرئيسي يوجد بها رغم ان الجهد الرئيسي
يوجد بها لكنه لم يحقق انجاز
اي حصل على التماس مع طريق مع شارع صلاح
الدين من شمال عبسان الجديده ومن جنوب ما
بين عبسان الكبيره وخزاعه ولكنه لم يستطع
ان يطور ه العمليات فطور الهجوم المساند
الذي اتى من مدينه حمد الى منطقه
جوش قطيف ودخل تقريبا دعني اقول في مدينه
غزه 270 درجه من الدائره الكليه تحت
الاشتباك طيب سياده اللواء الجزيره حصلت
على مشاهد جديده ل المعارك بين كتائب
القسام والجيش الاسرائيلي في خان يونس
جنوبي قطاع غزه كما قلت هناك المعارك كسر
العظم كما وصفتها
ن واعتقد منذ ايام هذه اول مره يتم نشر
فيديو من هذا النوع فيه استهداف للاليات
استهداف مباشر نعم نعم يعني الان هذه اللي
هي احنا شاهدنا الفيلم قبل ذلك هذه هي قاد
في التي بي جي اللي يستخدم ضد المباني ضد
الابنيه وهو استخدم في في هذا
الدور ونلاحظ انه الاستهداف يتم من فوق
اسطح المباني الم الان هذه الابنيه انا
انتبهت وشاهدناها متعدد الطبقات الثانيه
زاويه الرمايه زاويه تاخذ خط النظر الى
الاسفل الى الهدف نعم في حاله التي بي جي
تقريبا كان المباني متساويه من حيث
الارتفاع الان لاحظ الان الهدف و من اين
تاتي الرمايه زاويه رمعي ضيقه
لكن تم تحقيق الاصابه وعاده الاستهداف من
الاسطح ولكن يتم ايضا استهداف اسطح او سقف
دعنا نقول الدبابه الان اذا اتيح للرامي
امم ان يستهدف منطقه البرج فتعتبر الضربه
قاتله في اعلى الدبابه في اعلى الدبابه
البرج البرج هذا متحرك 360 درجه وال
المدفع ي جزء منه هذا الجزء الاضعف هذا
تقريبا حيث التصفيح الاضعف وبالتالي لا
اذا عندما تخترق القذيفه تلك المنطقه تدخل
الى تجويف الدبابه حيث يوجد ذخائر الدبابه
نفسها فتنفجر مع عمليه الانفجار نعم ايضا
هذا عرض لبعض المسيرات هذه ليست اول مره
نسمع الاستيلاء على مسيرات اسرائيليه يا
سيدي الان خلال الفتره الاخيره كثر الحديث
عن الطائرات المسيره وعن انواع الطائرات
المسيره لماذا لانه جيش
الاحتلال بدا يكثف من استخدامها في ادوار
الاستطلاع وفي ادوار القنس يعني كواد
كابتور في منها للاستطلاع وفي منها للقنص
وبالتالي زاد من وتيره استخ خدامها فزادت
وتيره اسقاط هذه هذه الطائرات الصغيره نعم
ايضا سرايا القدس تتحدث عن الاستيلاء على
مسيره اسرائيليه من نوع كواد كابتر كواد
كابتر الصغيره هذه اذا يعني يمكن المشاهد
يتذكر هذا في يوم
الكمين الذي نفذ باتقان عالي جدا كانت
كانت يعني ادخلت الى المبنى قبل ان يدخل
الجنود وقبل ادخال الكلاب فهي طائره اي
ترسل صور مستمره على مدار يعني ليس فقط
استولوا عليها ولكن تمكنوا من استخدامها
وبنجاح يا سيدي استخد سيطروا او نزلوا
اكثر من طائره هناك اذا اذا ذكرنا اسقاط
فالاس قط كانه باداه ايجابيه ام في
بالنيران عندما يتم تنزيلها اي بمعنى اخر
تعطيلها وتنزيلها يتم التح يعني الدخول
الى
نظام النظام الالكتروني او الكمبيوتري
الذي تعمل من خلاله ايضا هناك صور نشرها
الجيش الاسرائيلي كما يبدو لا ادري كيف
يمكن ان نصفه باعاده تموضع او اعاده
انتشار كان هناك ذكر ايضا لانسحاب كتيبه
اليوم كيف انت تصف ما يحدث الان ان تسحب
وحده من حاله الاشتباك هذا مفهوم
وكونسيلر القوات
قد تضطر في بعض الحالات ان ان تنخفض
القدره القتاليه عن 60 بال ولا يوجد
البديل اذا تستمر في القتال لكن للحفاظ
على الوحده وعلى ادائها المستقبلي
اذا كفاءتها القتاليه انخفضت دون ال 60%
تسحب لانها تصبح هدفا واهنا كما حدث في
الكتيبه 13 في الشجاعيه هذه الكتيبه لها
فتره طويله تقاتل تعرضت لعصابات الان ال
الاضرار التي الحقت بها ماديه بشريه
معنويه الان تصبح عبء على الوحدات الاخرى
بدل ان تكون هي جزء من القتال فيتم سحبها
واستبدالها نعم هذه حشود لدبابات هناك
تحرك للدبابات في غلاف غزه لا ادري اذا
كنت شاهدت هذا الفيديو يعني ما تقييمك
لهذه الصور او ما يحدث في غلاف غزه من من
قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي يعني هذه الاليات
اللي تتحرك انت يعني يوجد في المنطقه
الشماليه فرقتين في غلاق فزه يوجد في
المنطقه الو وسط فرقه زائد لوائين يوجد في
المنطقه الجنوبيه تحت قياده الفرقه 98
سبعه الويه وتسحب لواء ثمانيه عن ماذا
نتحدث نتحدث عن ما يقارب اكثر من خمسه فرق
نتحدث عن تقريبا اكثر من 1000 معد اليه
قتال وبالتالي هذا امر طبيعي جدا ان تكون
هذه الحركه يعني وبالتالي هذه الحركه تسمى
بالحركات التعبويه انا كقائد اشرف او ادير
ادير المعركه قد احتاج لنقل قوه من مكان
الى مكان حسب الواقع الميداني وبالتالي
هذه حركات في في ايام الحرب هي حركات
طبيعيه هل يمكن ان تكون مؤشرا
لهجوم بري مثلا حسف اتجاه الحركه قد تكون
في عمليه تراجع قد تكون عمليه التفاف
لمسانده وحده اخرى طبيعه الحركه
اسقاط الحركه على الجغرافيا هي اللي تعطيك
تعطيك الاجابه شكرا جزيلا اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي